a group of British museums has launched
a multi-million dollar campaign to keep
thousands of items salvaged from the
Titanic from falling into private hands
at a bankruptcy auction the effort is
backed by filmmaker James Cameron and
Robert Ballard who discovered the sunken
wreck on the Atlantic floor in 1985
Charlie d'Agata is in Greenwich London
Greenwich London outside one of the
museums fighting to preserve the
collection Charlie good morning good
morning the National Maritime Museum say
they're best equipped to look after
these artifacts in fact they already
house a small collection including a
watch that stopped the moment it
descended into those icy waters when the
Titanic went down in 1912 she took part
of America and Britain with her now
Britain wants those artifacts back home
where her journey began its museums have
the backing of Titanic movie director
James Cameron the sinking of Titanic was
a heartbreaking moment in history he
says it's a chance to honor the fifteen
hundred and three passengers and crew
who perished securing the irreplaceable
collection of artifacts protecting and
preserving them for future generations
by placing them in the public trust the
roughly 5,500 piece collection includes
personal items like jewelry cosmetics in
cash but the prized centerpiece is the
bronze cherub no not Leonardo DiCaprio
the statue
seen in the grand staircase seen in the
movie I saw that in a Nickelodeon once
now is the collection owner US company
premiere exhibitions Inc has filed for
bankruptcy
the wreck was discovered in 1985 by
former US Navy officer Robert Ballard
also part of the campaign all of the
people who fell to the bottom of the
ocean the only signature left are their
shoes and they're in pairs of shoes
mother's shoes with baby shoes and I
realized I was at a cemetery and nothing
should be taken from this site ballard
said he tried to block deep sea
expeditions from removing objects but
because the Titanic sank in
international waters it was finders
keepers
two the first salvage team to claim it
which is how it eventually fell into the
ownership of the US company British
Museum's argued the collection would be
better off here than lost to the world
of private ownership says National
Maritime Museum director Kevin Fewster
we're looking to buy the collection but
we're also wanting the courts to
recognize that there are principles at
stake here other than just money now
that includes looking after the wreckage
site that US Navy officer called it
hallowed ground saying you wouldn't take
a shovel to gettysburger go hunting for
belt buckles at Pearl Harbor yell it
does feel like hallowed ground thank you
very much Charlie d'Agata reporting from
Greenwich London you know I heard
something in the news interesting this
morning that it would have been it could
have been Matthew McConaughey and
Gwyneth Paltrow and the roles of Leo and
Kate Winslet
really they were in the running it's
hard to imagine anybody else in there oh
I love that movie interesting to see the
artifacts from the ship